in 2013 the company i co-founded soylent
broke crowdfunding records and raised
three million dollars for a bizarre
new food product that very few people
had actually tried
new direct-to-consumer e-commerce
companies are dying a dozen nowadays
but back then there wasn't an
established playbook for how to launch a
new product
we stumbled into one of the most
effective viral marketing techniques
by complete accident and my experience
launching soylent
still informs a lot of how i think about
business today
i'm john coogan and this is how we
launched soylent
i moved to silicon valley in 2012 with
the hope of starting a traditional
technology company
something that would live on the web or
in the app store and hopefully grow
exponentially like the many successful
tech companies that had come before
but building a great tech product proved
to be harder
than i originally thought my first
company was focused on education
technology
and was essentially a quiz app to help
students memorize flashcards in a fun
and interactive way
i was still learning to program and had
no idea how to actually grow a new
product after i published it
months went by and nothing i built
gained any traction
but this was extremely common most
startups fail after all
fortunately i had been living in a sort
of hacker house
with another startup that was going
through similar challenges
everyone was working hard and basically
coding around the clock
but we kept failing to get users and
actually grow the things that we built
it was a constant cycle of come up with
an idea
build a minimum viable product launch it
and then watch our analytics flatline
it was a tough experience but we really
enjoyed the process of building new
things
so the day-to-day work was actually
quite fun after my startup ran out of
the seventeen thousand dollars we had
raised in funding
i informally joined the other startup
team who still had about a hundred
thousand dollars left in funding from y
combinator
one of paul graham's most hilariously
simple pieces of startup wisdom
is just don't die he wrote an essay
where he said
if you can just avoid dying you get rich
that sounds like a joke
but it's actually a pretty good
description of what happens in a typical
startup
so we took this to heart with no revenue
coming in we set out to cut our expenses
as much as possible
we moved to a tiny one bedroom apartment
in the tenderloin district of san
francisco
where i slept on a twin bed in the
living room we paid our rent a year in
advance
so we at least knew that we would have a
place to live
as long as we were able to pay for food
and internet service we knew we could
continue to try new ideas until
something took off
i was still focused on writing code and
building traditional software startups
but one of the roommates rob reinhart
broadened his vision and started
researching biology
he noticed that we were spending most of
our money on food
and we were eating extremely unhealthy
diets of mostly ramen noodles and costco
corn dogs
so he started working on a solution that
would be healthy convenient
and affordable typically food options
only satisfy two of these criteria
nice restaurants are healthy and
convenient but expensive
fast food is convenient and affordable
but unhealthy
and growing your own food is affordable
and healthy but is inconvenient in a
tiny apartment
the idea he came up with was simple buy
the exact nutrients needed to satisfy
the fda recommended daily values
and blend them together into a drink
that was quick and cheap to make
he started tinkering with formulas and
to be honest the first time he told me
about the project
i wrote it off entirely i simply thought
that all viable startups had to be tech
companies
and that there was no way we could
launch a new food brand
it was an interesting experiment but i
didn't see how it could make any money
but rob liked the product he had made
and thought others might too
so he started blogging about his
experience he posted a lengthy blog post
on february 13th of 2013
where he detailed his experience using
the soylent prototype formula
and shared how his health had improved
while using the product exclusively
rob has always been a creative writer
and he has a knack for crafting
interesting and provocative narratives
he called the piece how i stopped eating
food and explained that he had been
using soylent exclusively for 30 days
straight
with only positive health changes to
show for it
the blog post received mixed reviews on
hacker news with some people claiming it
was satirical
while others claimed it must be a scam
but a few people were genuinely engaging
with the ideas
and said that they would like to try the
formula as long as they could
independently vet the ingredients
so rob posted the ingredients the next
day and the idea started to grow
soon reporters from vice magazine and
discovery news
started interviewing rob to hear about
the experiment and seemingly overnight
10 000 people had signed up on an
extremely simple landing page to try the
product when it was available
with so much organic interest in the
product we were able to launch a
crowdfunding campaign
that raised three million dollars which
was a record for food products at the
time
and still stands in the consumer package
goods category after working for nearly
a year on failed idea after failed idea
we had finally lucked into something
that spoke to people and was able to
gain organic traction
we didn't realize it at the time but by
stress testing soylent on himself
by eating it exclusively for 30 days
straight rob had stumbled upon one of
the oldest marketing techniques around
david ogilvy is known as the father of
advertising and had one of the most
successful careers in advertising
throughout the 20th century
he's produced iconic advertisements for
rolls-royce
dove and countless other american
heritage brands
in 1963 ogilvy published confessions of
an advertising man
which is still remarkably relevant today
even though the mediums have shifted
from radio to podcasts
from tv to instagram and from newspapers
to tweets
all of the methods he outlines speak to
fundamental human nature
and are therefore timeless he has a
chapter in his book titled
how to make tv commercials that sell
where he outlines a variety of
techniques like humor
testimonials problem solution and
emotion
these are all still used regularly today
but he highlights demonstrations
as particularly effective he says that
demonstrations don't have to be dull
and shares one particularly interesting
commercial that his firm
created for the super glue brand loctite
in the ad super glue is applied to the
soles of an actor's shoes
before lifting him onto the ceiling
where he sticks
and hangs upside down the visual is
quite striking and it makes sure that
the actor will have the viewers full
attention while delivering the sales
pitch
the ad was so successful that it made
loctite superglue
the brand leader and the commercial won
first prize at the con festival
this ad has even been remade by loctite
and directly copied by
several competitors over the past few
decades
the strategy of a shocking demonstration
has also been used to sell other
products like dog food
back in the 1980s alpo dog food had
hired the actor lorne greene
as a spokesperson and in each commercial
they were careful to point out that
lorne
indeed fed alpo to his dogs it's also a
bit of a legend that the president of
call con pet food
would personally eat a can of his
company's dog food
at the annual shareholders meeting each
year but one can of dog food isn't
nearly as impressive as a full month of
dog food
so naturally mitch felderhoff the
president of the munster milling company
ate nothing but munster brand dog food
for 30 days at the start of 2020
the marketing stunt worked for munster
milling and the press covered mitch's
dog food diet extensively
these extreme demonstrations are good
for two reasons
first they let the customer know that
you have faith in your product
and are willing to put your own body on
the line to test it
before products have independent reviews
customer testimonials
or slick ads sometimes the only advocate
for the product
is the founder the second benefit of a
stress test
is that it is extremely hard to ignore
some people love these stunts
some people hate them but very few
people can disregard them entirely
everyone had an opinion on soylent when
we launched it which meant lots of
attention
the press wanted to hear the full story
and people who read stories about
soylent
couldn't resist commenting on how crazy
this silicon valley guy was
for giving up food entirely for 30 days
straight
now is a stress test demonstration right
for every product launch
absolutely not it's only appropriate
when your product is significantly
different from the competition
and would naturally draw a lot of
skepticism from potential customers
but that doesn't mean that it's not
important to focus on telling a
compelling story
when you launch the product there are
plenty of founders who lament the fact
that no journalist wants to write
about what they are building but
journalists only write about things that
people will read
they need to find compelling stories
good stories have clear narrative arcs
for soylent it was a broke entrepreneur
struggling to find a way to stay healthy
who took a big risk by testing a new
product on himself for 30 days straight
it's a dramatic story like someone
walking a tightrope between two
buildings
will they fall will rob's soylent
experiment wind up having some
unforeseen health consequences
it's human nature to want to find out
what happens
so that's how we launched soylent we
focused on making a product that solved
a real problem we had
ourselves and then we told the world
about it in the most dramatic way
possible
none of us had studied marketing or even
heard of david ogilvy before
but we knew what made for an interesting
experiment and that sharing detailed
information would spark people's
interest
hopefully you enjoyed this video i'm
planning to post a few more about my
personal entrepreneurial experiences
so please subscribe to the channel if
you haven't already if you'd like to get
in touch with me
just reach out on twitter and as always
thanks for watching